[Music]
straight ahead on long crime daily
a federal judge accepts the plea deal
for convicted murderer derek shovin but
first it's the battle of the hollywood
x's as amber heard takes the stand for a
second day it felt like there was a
blackness in his eyes i wanted to look
at him i wanted him to
see me it didn't even feel like him
how she says ex-husband johnny depp felt
about her co-stars he
hated
hated
james franco how actor james franco
caused a marital spat and later nothing
i did made him stop hitting me
nothing straight from the fairfax county
courthouse we break down day 15 of
testimony long crime daily covering
court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to long time daily i'm
your host brian buckmeyer amber hurt is
back on the stand to detail what she
describes as a toxic relationship with
ex-husband johnny depp law and crimes
network long crime network's jesse weber
is at the fairfax county courthouse in
virginia to break down day 15 of
testimony jesse
yeah brian amber heard continued
describing for the jury different
episodes of alleged abuse that she
suffered at the hands of johnny depp she
began by once again focusing on depp's
drug and alcohol issues she recalled
times that depp would get sick and pass
out even authenticating pictures that
she took of depth seemingly showing this
she described how when depp was filming
mordhai he wouldn't be able to make it
on set and how on one occasion depp's
security guard carried him home like a
baby it was this behavior that heard
says led to death becoming increasingly
more verbally abusive of her namely
picking fights about her choice to work
as an actress her getting involved with
his children and she claims he would
become controlling and jealous
particularly over possible intimate
scenes on films in fact actor james
franco became a hot button issue between
the couple he was mad at me
for taking the job with james franco he
hated
hated
james franco
and was
already accusing
me
of kind of secretly having a thing with
him in my past since we had done
pineapple express together we take off
and at some point he
he's asking me why what's wrong with me
what do i have do i have something to
tell him do i have something to tell him
you want to talk to me about your day
yesterday and then it gets
i i already know that he's
drunk
i already know he's using
um he reeks
of weed and alcohol i mean his breath
smelled so bad and i could
i i could anticipate that there was a
no-win situation here there was no me
talking myself out of this or talking
him down or any
you know a lot of my arguments and my
involvement in them
are me trying to
defuse by explaining objection
non-responsive and from there heard
would describe in harrowing detail how
depp would allegedly physically attack
her including on that infamous 2014
flight from boston to l.a where she says
depp threw things at her slapped her and
kicked her brian
thank you jesse joining us today is
criminal defense attorney mike
corrobonix and co-host terry austin mike
the issue or discussion i foresee in
deliberations is what is domestic
violence exactly when especially when
both parties participate could that
leave a jury hung or does it matter if
heard participated in the violence at
some point in time in the relationship
it's such an interesting question brian
because it's some type of question that
we're really not used to seeing having
to be answered because of the fact you
have two people testifying as to
these violent episodes now the jury's
got to decide who was abusing who or if
in fact were these episodes as violent
as they were described that seems to be
very interesting and i think because
there it seems so
opposite at times that the jury may have
a really strict
kind of division in making a decision in
this case being on one side or the other
yeah can you be both victim and
perpetrator it's not something we we
often have to answer now terry the
standard for depth to win his defamation
claim is that he has to prove heard is
acting maliciously in these false
statements with so many allegations of
violence how can depth attorneys be
successful here
oh i definitely think they can be
successful
what hurt is doing on this stand is
talking about so many acts of violence
and she's saying that he slapped her he
punched her he kicked her and she was
violently tossed across the room she hit
the wall if all of those things were
true she would have more damage more
injury and more abuses and no one has
seen that not only are there no pictures
but no one has testified that they've
ever seen her with that sort of
substantial damage so i think the jury
could just discount everything she has
to say and not believe a single instance
of where there might have actually been
some violence so i think she's overdoing
it and i think that the jury could just
discount everything yeah to your point
one thing that stuck out to me is johnny
depp wears a lot of rings and she's
testified to that fact if you get hit
with a hand with that many rings
i would expect some serious damage but
we haven't seen that yet her case is
still going maybe she puts on a witness
to testify otherwise but we'll have to
keep watching to see how that plays out
still ahead on law and crime daily our
johnny depp versus amber heard trial
coverage continues amber heard describes
the first time depp got physical with
her in front of an audience how she said
depp's friends and employees reacted
[Music]
welcome back we're taking a closer look
now at day two of testimony for
defendant amber heard on thursday she
told jurors about the first time depp
got physical with her in front of other
people saying it standing from comments
about james franco on a plane ride from
boston to los angeles
did i ask
james to do this and this to me and how
about if he does those things to me
ex insert
sexually explicit descriptions of what
he
accused me of
wanting or deserving
and i at some point in this get up
and move to the front of the planet
johnny came to me each time not the
other way around
he sits down in front of me at one point
and
because i'm not answering him i was
looking out of the window
and he slaps my face
and
his
friend
is in our proximity
and i
it didn't hurt my it didn't hurt my face
it just felt embarrassed
did you do that to me in front of people
it was the first time that anything like
that had happened in front of somebody
and i just
look at him one more time
wanting to penetrate the monster to see
the man that i love underneath that
the man i loved
and he tells me to hurry up again
and i pull my gaze away from him i walk
away from him
my back is turned to him and i feel this
boot
in my back
it just kicked me
in the back
i
fell to the floor i caught myself on the
floor and i just felt like i was looking
at the
floor of the plane for a felt like a
long time
and i didn't i thought to myself i don't
know what to do
i can't believe he just did he just
kicked me
no one said anything no one did anything
it was like you could
you could hear a pin drop on that plane
terry now we've been critiquing heard's
body language while depp was testifying
so now let's do the same for depp he's
been laughing and looking down during
herd's testimony so how would the school
of terry austin great his demeanor
look i think perception is everything
they have to sit there and listen to
that testimony for weeks at a time it
cannot be easy to do that particularly
when you're hearing things you don't
want to hear things that you think might
be lying i would tell him to be a little
bit more stoic i do think that he can
lean over talk to the attorney when he
hears something particularly as it
relates to violence and i do think he
can snicker sometimes when he hears
something that is so outrageous but you
have to be careful because then the jury
is going to say well why didn't you
snicker at that so most of the time i
would advise him to be straightforward
don't say much if things look like
they're not true maybe lean over maybe
take a note but for the most part try to
take it seriously and try not to look
like you are demeaning what she has to
say yeah that's a good point because
you're always kind of on the stand
when you're in the courtroom not just
when you're testifying mike you listen
to this direct examination and that
little snippet there uh what are two
points of cross-examination you would
question heard about on this issue of
alleged assault on the plane
well the first one i asked i'd ask for a
basic catalog of all the people who were
present when this happened who said
nothing
and then asked if any of those people
who were there are going to testify
because either way whether or not that's
a question you're not going to lose any
ground in because you're going to
show the jury that either these people
are not going to come testify or if they
are coming you're prepared for them so i
think that's where you go because when
you have a case like this and you're
saying something this dramatic happened
with such a famous person as johnny depp
you would think someone would at least
put it on twitter or instagram
yeah uh maybe this is a situation where
everyone's staying silent or
maybe this is a situation where everyone
saw what happened and did not interpret
it as abuse right now it seems like it's
50 50 until we get some sort of
corroboration in this he said she said
allegation thank you both for the
updates on that let's
keep going forward with johnny depp it's
exciting coming up on law and crime
daily even more testimony from amber
heard she had missed a hitting death but
was it in self-defense
plus can herds legal team keep up with
the objections from depths attorneys our
legal analysts break down her case so
far
[Music]
welcome back we're zeroing in on the
direct examination of amber heard on
thursday she told juras depp was
controlling about what movie roles she
would take depending on sex scenes with
co-stars or nudity she also described
when she started violently retaliating
to death's alleged abuse
in these fights
we tried to stand up for myself by
december 2014
i was pushing back i'd push him off of
me i tried to hit his hands away
i tried to always get back up which
sometimes not sometimes almost always
made it worse
and we seem to provoke him
um
but i tried
and worse i you know i would
yell at him i'd scream at him
i calm ugly names
so ashamed of the names we'd call each
other it was awful
it was awful we both
got into that pattern it was so
you know i felt so angry that this was
happening to me and i felt it just felt
so
unfair you know
it felt like
nothing i could do felt like nothing i
could do would change the sobriety
patterns felt like nothing i could do
would stand up for him and nothing i did
made him stop hitting me
nothing
so
you know i tried for
over a year maybe maybe two
of just not responding physically not
responding verbally just staring at him
i tried to freeze i tried to
go to a different place i just i would
try then lashing out verbally i would
try to
threaten that if he hit me again that i
would call the police you know police
were called several times but
i tried to do everything i even
threatened to leave him you know and
tried to leave him and nothing was
working
and i think by this point in our
relationship
um
we're both saying awful things to each
other
screaming at each other and
unfortunately
when johnny would start hitting me he'd
just win
i'll subscribe it
similar to when johnny depp was on the
stand throughout herd's second day of
testimony were freaking objections from
depp's team which prompted several
sidebars at one point the judge even
reprimanded heard's attorneys for the
evidence organization
objection calls for speculation and
hearsay did there come a time that you
did move in
with him objection leading
your honor i'm going to object on
hearsay
he's gonna that might cost objection
your honor hearsay objection hearsay
her communications are hearsay i tried
to say
that it was fine
i found out that he was in a hotel room
with paul projection hearsay did you
have with lily rose without saying
anything she said objection hearsay
objection leading if we approach and
then your kid's in the car on the street
here say objection form compound
i i'll allow it but just
trying to keep the record clear 272 has
already been entered into evidence
without that reactions and there wasn't
any objection so i if i could have both
sides to keep track of their evidence
it's not my
job to keep
this it's really the party's
responsibility to take care of the
record not mine my apologies on that one
you're out
terry as heard testifies on direct is
she beginning to sound more and more
credible to you
not in my opinion as a matter of fact
the more she says the less credible she
sounds she just takes all of these
situations and makes it seem as though
he as i mentioned before is violent all
day every day and i think the jury is
listening to this and they see it's an
act at one point she basically talked on
and on about the incident in australia
and she claims that you know he pushed
her shoved her hit her head against the
wall that's also where she claimed he
sexually assaulted her and i think the
jury is looking at this and saying it's
just too much i don't believe all of
this that you have to say and the crying
the looking like she's trying to bring
on tears it's just over the top and i
think she's looking less and less
credible as her direct testimony goes on
yeah
mike i'm i'm having like flashbacks as
i'm hearing this testimony every time i
hear heard's lawyers i can hear my my
evidence professor beth belmont uh
objection objection um is this struggle
to admit evidence going to hurt herds
case overall
i i always think it hurts the case when
when you struggle to put in evidence and
especially when objections come to take
the questioner that attorney off track
and that's sometimes what the strategy
is from objections because
a lot of these questions i don't know if
i'd object to but they're objecting to
it and it is throwing the
them off track in their testimony so i
think it's effective but i do think it's
a little bit too many objections are
sustained and the case can move quicker
i was trying to find something to object
there to throw you off but i couldn't
find anything mike i would agree i think
it's it's both strategic but also
true fair enough uh but i think it is
smart it's strategic but it's also
keeping out certain facts because when
it comes to closing all those things
that we're objected to can't come in at
closing it's not evidence i think we're
gonna see an extremely extremely messy
summation from amber hertz team and i
think it's gonna hurt her chances at
winning but we gotta wait and see as
that progresses but of course to keep up
with the gavel to gavel coverage of the
johnny depp versus amber heard trial
make sure to follow our newest podcast
lawn crime sidebar listen in as law and
crime's top hosts recap the highs and
lows of the trial so far straight from
the fairfax county courthouse in
virginia subscribe on apple podcast or
online at lawncrime.com
when we come back derek shovin's name is
back in the headlines details of his
plea agreement on federal charges of
depriving george floyd of his civil
rights
[Music]
welcome back famous actor and comedian
dave chappelle shaken up after being
tackled on stage by a replica handgun
which contained a knife blade during a
show in los angeles the audience member
who allegedly attacked chappelle has
been identified as 23 year old isaiah
lee according to the district attorney
he is not facing felony charges lee was
caught in a shocking video footage
racing towards chappelle and knocking
him down with a flying tackle security
then chased lee before he was caught lee
was hospitalized after security got
involved allegedly twisting his arm and
snapping it after the attack chappelle
joked about how he beat a person up
backstage he then was comforted by on
stage by famous comedian chris rock who
jerkingly said was that will smith after
the infamous slap heard around the world
at the oscars in march
and in minnesota a federal judge has
accepted a plea agreement with former
minneapolis police officer derek shovin
over violating george floyd's civil
rights in december chauvin pled guilty
to violating floyd's rights admitting he
kept his knee on floyd's neck even after
he stopped pleading i can't breathe and
became unresponsive chopin would be
sentenced to 20 to 25 years in prison
but will get credit for the time he
already served the federal judge
deferred accepting chauvin's plea until
after a pre-sentencing investigation now
no sentencing date has been set for
chauvin for the federal deal last year
he was sentenced to 22 and a half years
for his murder conviction at the state
level though he's appealing it as part
of the deal showing waves his right to
appeal the federal conviction two tao
thomas lane and jay alexander king were
all convicted of depriving floyd of his
civil rights of in federal court their
state trial for charges of aiding and
abetting both murder and manslaughter is
set to begin in june
mike taking a plea on fed on the federal
case but appealing the state case on
multiple grounds does that leave chauvin
in some kind of legal limbo or is there
a direction we can see these cases going
well i don't see the appeal going
forward in the state case just because
they filed it don't me doesn't mean you
have to follow through with it i am sure
once you take a plea in federal court
and the judge accepts it you basically
waived your appellate rights so he's
looking at that amount of time i would
be very surprised if the federal case
was negotiated and came to that
resolution saying we'll take a plea here
but you can go appeal the other case so
i think those are both going to be run
together and i think the appeal will be
withdrawn that's just my opinion i mean
it makes sense especially because you
got 20 to 20 have 20 to 25 years in the
feds and on the state 22 and a half run
it concurrent serve your time in the
federal prison i think that's the plan
but we'll see how it plays out terry
when shoving was convicted in the state
case he said he couldn't say anything
because of this federal case now that
it's done should we expect a statement
from him well i think it would be great
if he made a statement it would be
you know comforting to the
people who actually were affected to the
family but i don't think we're going to
see that i think chauvin really does
seem like the type of person who doesn't
say much he doesn't make many statements
he didn't say much during the trial
obviously and he hasn't made any
statements subsequent to the state trial
and i think that you know frankly he
probably made this plea deal he knows
they're going to be running concurrent
the federal 20 to 25 like you said the
concurrent with the state which is 22.5
what more can he say i do think he
should though i do think it would be
great this is a huge case and saying
something would be really good for the
public absolutely well thank you very
much both and thank you for joining us
here on lawn crime daily we'll see you
next time as we discuss justice in
america
[Music]
you